oh my god this gasp is gonna like
destroy everything that we know until it
breaks the Gatsby is gonna get me
deported we are one hand someone one of
our neighbors banged on the door they
banged on the wall what's the problem I
can't make a little noise in my own
office oh the door just opened welcome
everybody they say pocket we're gonna
need a new door today's episode is
sponsored by yours truly Oh Jay Simpson
and hello not OJ Simpson hello fresh and
ring is sponsored by we have no
affiliation with OJ they give their
friends just to be clear we are
affiliated with hellofresh and ring
today
I come to you with the news that Eva has
undergone her oath ceremony and you
turned in your green card and it's
official you are a full-blown US citizen
now I cannot afford it I just got here
from the ceremony right and it was so
weird to give them my green card I feel
like it's part of my identity
yeah sure that green card it's like you
always got to have it on you and now
it's like it's not on me and so you hire
stranger Fickett but I'm I'm curious
they gave me a certificate and I guess
now I can apply for it passports what
you need is the passport right Wow
congratulations that's really exciting
thank
we've also I have footage of that
actually here I have footage of us so I
had no idea what to expect and there
were so many people like to be exact
there were 3,700 people just in my
ceremony I think they do it 3700 yeah I
thought it was gonna be like 20 people I
didn't meet my phone man honestly by
ringing on the door I got my phone blown
up that was a ring notification by the
way yeah that's what it sounds like calm
sponsor this episode bring accomplished
h3 so I thought it would be like 20
maybe 20 people and I thought I'm gonna
go in a stage Thomsen shakes your hand
yes that I was gonna read the oath and
we were gonna record it it's not at all
you're like one of literally 3,700
people and then they read the oath on
this stage and then everyone repeats it
well I guess we are in like the second
most populated city in America
mm-hmm meet that we'll check that but
mmhmm yeah Los Angeles is number 2 by
New York so I guess I shouldn't be
surprised that you had so many people
there but god damn yeah so it looks like
they do it a few times a day - I don't
know what a few times a day maybe not
marry it's not every day I don't know
how frequently they do it but it looked
like it was set up for more than one
holy ceremony so tell me about what was
tell me about it you were in there with
4,000 people what would happen what
happened
lots of waiting and waiting and then
they had a few music videos oh really
yeah that's pretty funny like like why
why was America weird like music thank
God for the USA oh and the founding
fathers and well that's and then we had
a video from Trump congratulating us
What did he say he said I don't remember
like you know congratulating us and then
that it's very special I'm surprised you
didn't throw in some like
congratulations on becoming a u.s.
citizen half of you I wish would have
not passed the exam I'm working to that
no but what did you feel like a like an
honor because I saw you guys someone
saying the hose that star-spangled
banner
you made the oh did it feel lighter like
I mean you know pretty nice and pretty
there was an emotional part with the
judge there's like it's like they make
it a court even though it's just it's
not I think back in the day yeah we'll
have one due to one court
all right so it needs to be a court so
there was a judge there well and she
said that it's very like like emotional
for her cuz she was once in our shoes oh
so that was kind of cool that is cool
she got Theory really yeah but she told
her story of she came here with her
parents and she tell that have twice a
day that story though I don't know and
she twice a day I wonder that too what
if that was just a special thing for
maybe but the room was probably electric
because a lot of this big dildo to a lot
of the people in that room I mean every
yeah that room was probably yeah deal
and they kept saying this is your day
and everyone's like yeah I saw that they
were all going crazy from their American
flags yeah it's a beautiful thing man
marriage is so great it's good cuz you
got to become an Israeli citizen and
like what was that for you he's not no
there's nothing yeah
basically there's there's nothing it's
true America they make it they make it a
special thing because it is I I love
America I've been learning about America
a lot through year I mean stuff that I
already knew that I learned as a child
but stuff that you can't really
appreciate as a young child but as an
adult when you learn about the
founding fathers and and what they went
through and why and thank you and why
they established this beautiful America
the thirteen states they came together
to what the ideals that freedom that men
can govern themselves that freedom is an
inalienable right bestowed upon us by
the one true creator that no man could
ever take away these are ideas that had
never been ingrained in a government
before democracy was born here in
America and put into action action the
American experience is just incredible
did you know that George Washington
owned like 300 slaves and upon his death
he freed them all because he came to
learn that slavery was a was it what it
did not work with their idea of what
freedom meant he came to understand that
through the influence of people like
Alexander Hamilton while his old life
was against slavery these men they
fought and died your heart think no I
just get excited I love ya I love
democracy and I love America yeah we the
people I know that now and oh they had
someone sing the national from the video
okay
that was pretty cool it's beautiful and
I finally understood the lyrics like you
know I always hear it and I have no idea
what they're saying because it's kind of
hard they give you a lyrics yeah I like
that it says that it's the home of the
free and the brave that's right home of
the holy land of the brave yeah it's
true the men who fought you know when
the Revolutionary War went down
everybody thought America had no [ __ ]
chance Great Britain the kingdom that
greatest empire that ever existed to
that point the world power it was a
world superpower
they America was supposed to get their
face stomped in mm-hmm
but these they are brave and they are
free [ __ ] did it
they beat the English dude do you know
what I'm saying yeah we just watched
that Alexander Hamilton so this is why
George Washington is such a badass
I love their name and the fourth George
Washington they say he's the best one he
a lot of people say is the best
president of all time he set that
precedent people wanted him to be king
but he said no I will only serve two
terms I will set this important
precedent because we are a democracy we
are not a monarchy mm-hmm it's crazy all
this stuff that we're just used to the
American exactly we need to we need the
room anyway thank you for becoming a
citizen I'm so proud of you and I'm glad
that nobody could kick you out of the
country now for our high jinks so if you
kill somebody you cannot be deported you
can lose your right to vote but you
cannot be deported you can still be on
Twitter
yes you can still tweet nobody yes the
founding fathers say freedom is an
inalienable right and as well as
tweeting have the freedom to bear
twitter honey mm-hmm tweeting is an
unalienable right so here let's watch
this video of you sending that video
that I got it this is like a Google my
why not one day game and this mag that's
when I was like oh [ __ ]
this is real when they hand you the flag
on the way oh and you're walking
actually hello [ __ ] yeah
damn I was never issued a flag a little
bit and your mom was sitting at the back
of they separate you from the applicants
and the guests and your mom was with
theatre and there were so many people
and I gave her my phone because we
wanted her to record if there's any good
footage and I wasn't sure if her phone
was good so I was sitting with no phone
it was like maybe for three hours and
lots of waiting with no phone is pretty
horrible feeling and then I'm
unalienable right the eye I couldn't see
them there were so many people I had no
idea where they were and then I kept
hearing like babies crying I was like oh
[ __ ] what is it going on
I hope the theatre is fine but just to
give you guys an idea yeah yeah exactly
you can't see so many [ __ ] people on
the left that's all the applicants all
of this and on the right is all the
guests
where was it was it in a big stadium
yeah remember where um III was 300 the
convention where was it what all right
Convention Center oh yeah it's Dan oh my
goodness so the government's shelling
out some major dollars to rent to rent a
space man
yeah holy [ __ ] they could you know they
could just give you a certificate and
say oh but they they go that extra mile
they do and that's feel special because
let's face it our forebears fought hard
and long during the Revolutionary War
when they said you won't stand a chance
when the 13 original States the half of
them didn't even want to fight because
they didn't think that we stood a chance
to get the English but there was a
special few who stood up and said no we
will not stand against tyranny about
with taxation without representation we
will not stand without religious freedom
freedom of speech freedom of the press
we have these unalienable rights we have
the pursuit of happiness like liberty
and justice for all
these are the American ideals that we
would put a flag in the sand and we said
this is America and we fought huh and we
died we starved we ate our horses we
were famished
hey yes we ate our horses because we had
a lack of supplies that heroin you know
what I'm saying and goddamnit
Liam when that white flag waved we look
to God and we said freedom is my
god-given birthright then no man could
ever take and I bow my head in reverence
until I forked and I thank God and Jesus
in George Washington first of his name
Mount Vernon that stands forever so I
have a dumb question hoots now that I
know all the figures who's on the amount
and the Mount Rushmore yeah so let's see
we've got we got we got George
Washington here let me pull it up father
of our country
he is the father of our country George
Washington such a [ __ ] badass you know
people always try to scrutinize him
because a lot of people go back in
history and they try to be like rewrite
and try to figure out how this guy was a
George Washington is one of the only
people in American history that stands
up to scrutiny
he's described by those who knew him as
a god-like figure he was he was a
principled he was fair he was balanced
they said of him first to war first to
freedom
George washing is what he said of him
you know what I'm saying dude this guy
is such a badass
he owned a bunch of slaves he was born
into a family that owned slaves he
inherited his slaves from his family so
he you know when you're when you were
raised that way it's difficult and I'm
such a divisive issue at the time but
near the end of his life he came to
understand that it was at odds the
ideals of freedom you have George
Washington here
wait for it Jefferson come on hold on
Thomas Jefferson yes was he like he was
the guard president Thomas Jefferson was
the third president right he was that he
was the political rival of Alexander him
yes he was from the south
Hamilton was in charge of big government
he's going to establish the Federal
Reserve Hamilton was opposed to all the
or Jefferson was opposed to all those
things but he was a great American
obviously Teddy Roosevelt the one and
only and of course Abraham Lincoln nice
so a testament to our great to our great
leaders came before us very cool yeah
that's pretty sick that they just like
[ __ ] yeah apparently is supposed to
be a more epic but they like ran out of
funds and stuffed working I think yeah I
think that's you like [ __ ] this stone
man who's got time for this [ __ ] yeah
something to finish it I think Trump
should be up there no Trump would do
that right the Commission himself to be
added that honestly looks incredible
though here's that go
I wanna go there look at that that looks
so good chopped into the mountainside
that's sick dude Teddy Roosevelt was one
of the most badass human beings ever
Teddy Roosevelt was like used to ride
into war dude with the Rough Riders and
[ __ ] kill Indians bro you would
killed so many Indians I think it
probably is but he's the one to be fair
all these guys probably killed [ __ ]
loads Indians yes that's true
but he's the one that established
national parks mm-hmm
he was like he was all about nature and
preserving the beautiful nature of our
country Teddy Roosevelt George
Washington Oh such a legend god bless
his soul anyway congratulations ela
thank you we're all very proud of you we
by the way the main thrust of this
episode is that we have got an
investigative journalist on the ground
at area 51 on September 21st the day of
the event tiny no 20th whatever was he
was there on the day of the event Ground
Zero interviewing people talking to
people we've got that here today an HP
podcast exclusive mm-hmm so that's
what's coming up a little bit later we
had our Teddy fresh rip and dip event in
New York City that's where we were last
Friday it was a blast was ahead it was
so much fun I thank everyone who came
out I mean the turnout was amazing I was
whenever I do these meetups I'm all the
back of my mind I'm like bye people here
yeah the morning of we were both kind of
like scared that no one's gonna show up
or something but you know you I don't
know man you guys just you just never
know what to expect
yeah I know but you guys are hey you
know we're not making like YouTube video
like main video so I don't know if
people [ __ ] whatever but they came
out you guys came out and it was
wholesome it was beautiful we had armed
guards there they didn't even have to
draw
the security was amazing they were armed
just so any of you guys know that you
were buying some [ __ ] but they didn't
have to another weapon no it was
fantastic here's some of the footage I
haven't seen this actually everyone was
telling us the line was crazy but I mean
we couldn't really know what were there
for five hours from 11:00 till 4:00 I
don't know what time this was you know
that a French faces in the crowd man you
guys are awesome good there was all
kinds of people onto the street looking
into the windows like I think they
probably expect someone more famous
mm-hmm
they're like who's in there all these
tourists you know because we're in like
a fashion district of Manhattan and I
love that piece
and but man everyone was so nice I was
just so happy yeah damn it was so sweet
it was so cool it's nice to just people
like you know I listen to your podcast
lots of comments on a podcast yeah lots
of nice words for you guys back there by
the way yeah Ian and Dan and lots of
happy birthdays - Zach yep I said oh
yeah this girl we were just gonna leave
and this girl was Gatlin okay we should
do a podcast meet up sometime for you
for you guys to meet everyone this is a
band where we couldn't see everyone yeah
this music sick dandy third I window
thanks I wrote it myself okay
rippen dip calm you can still grab the
collection although a lot of it's sold
out which is insane - there's the main
pieces are still there the hoodies and
stuff thank you guys oh my god I'm a
flattered beyond words I'm humbled I'm
flattered I'm thrilled and I'm
especially glad that security didn't
have to kill any money but I went up to
the security I was like yo you guys just
keep your eyes open it's a crazy time
keep your finger on the trigger
Oh
and as we took taxis to the
meet-and-greet one for us and one for my
mom and my sister who were all also
there they came to watch the other and
we get out and about to start the meet
and greet and then he things like oh
[ __ ] I don't have my back yeah
everything even lost his bag alone thing
yeah well I want to be one of the rip
and dip people tracked him down somehow
and I got all my [ __ ] back yeah but
ain't but I was amazed now dude yeah I
would've been so [ __ ] without that but
anyway I was to the security I was like
keep your finger on the trigger bro
you ready to draw at any moment so
luckily nobody died but thank you guys
for coming out seriously and you don't
know how close you were to being killed
my day so I was like if anyone hugs me
too long bro that's what I said to them
so some of you guys who are really
enthusiastic to meet me may have died on
this day so but anyway nobody died and
I'm just very thankful for that
right ela I guess that crowd sounds so
cool man anyway yeah trip and dip calm
if you want to grab some pieces there's
a lot sold out it's doing incredibly
well I'm so I'm so thankful most lecture
there and what I do want to say a lot of
times people ask so this stuff we we
don't restock it's a one-time thing okay
just so you know if you're wondering
that's how it goes and that's how we
like to do it with that collab yeah I'd
be rare it's a national thing yeah they
are available at Zumiez - yeah yep
exactly
but the plush doll the slippers ooh
beiiy be anyway that's all the good
things have been going on in our life
and I also before we get into all the
meat and potatoes I want to give a happy
and gay or happy wedding to yours truly
[Applause]
look at the beautiful married I mean
love these two such sweet these two are
so sweet
so congrats on aisle of both of them we
should send them again yeah I totally
missed that I just actually did just
happen yeah okay they look great
Jason clean up first of all she looks
beautiful yeah your gown is beautiful
but she's a pretty girl that doesn't
surprise me Jason cleans up like one
time I saw him he like cut his hair and
he looked real nice the second time ago
vodka he cleans up good man he looks
good dude that's really nice I love
these guys god bless them all god bless
everybody just don't hug me too long or
I will pull a weapon on you right either
no okay let's see I did the Gatsby entry
I had knocked the door off the hinges we
talked about all this okay see nice that
is joining us on Friday there's question
thread on this table ready for that
Casey nice that ladies and gentlemen
that's cool we've got all kinds of [ __ ]
I was really organized but now my dog is
a [ __ ] mess because it's not your
fault Dan cuz you just did what I told
you to do but he put a bunch of links at
the top and it I thought I could handle
it but I can't and it's just throwing me
off completely so I've got all I've got
like a cringe trifecta here for us today
it's a trinity of cringe I've got a
pregnancy cringe I've got a cringe pants
and I've got a cringe interview it's a
trifecta they're all special wonderful
beautiful cringe snowflakes of their own
decorating let's start with the cringe
pregnancy this one was making its rounds
on Twitter quite popular if I'm being
honest with you guys it's got almost 9
million views on Twitter my first
reaction was I was like man these guys
got to be youtubers or something this
[ __ ] is so corny but in actuality I
think it was a tick tock I mean there
are love pits yeah the vertical kind of
tells me that it was not you two
there's pits of hell lower than
YouTube like Dante's uh you know
Dante's levels of Hell so I thought
YouTube was the lowest level but
apparently not now first of all ABC News
I mean what what the [ __ ] are you doing
why who are you
they go you were my best friend soul
mate and just in a few pushes you'll be
the most amazing mother or daughter
could ever ask for
that's annoying statement just a few
bushes she's not even in labor by the
way I mean it is but she's not like on
the she's not in the delivery room but
it's almost like rude it's more than
just a few pushes like shut up
right just a few pushes that's all that
it yeah just a few tears your whole
body's gonna tear also just some months
of recovery maybe she won't be the best
mother and a couple pushes maybe takes
time
maybe being parented a little more to it
than a couple pushes dude well anyway
why is ABC tweeting this they say
husband of the Year surprises pregnant
wife with book of motivational message
to encourage her during two-day labor
now guys think about this the the
notepad is pouring out to torch the
camera my uh Michael from Schmo yo so
here you could read it right this is the
orientation you cannot she can't even
read what's on the paper can you read
that ela that's review I mean to be fair
the text is really big okay but dude
it's not facing me well we got a watch
because I don't understand
angle yet alright husband of the year
I got competition here illa ABC News
ain't [ __ ] they got inmates we dating
videos about my ass being husband of the
year I can already tell you the
motivational messages isn't the last
thing I would want to hear that's what I
keep seeing a lot of women saying like
if my husband tried this [ __ ]
during the but anyway this is all
[ __ ] they planned this ahead of time
for views its look at the shot what
their stunts like dude homie said okay I
see what you mean yeah it's not even
facing
thinker like I don't read it maybe if
she squinted she could read it if it's
for her why isn't him facing her yeah
because they wanted to put her stomach
in the shot to sell it right this is
probably not even his first take if I'm
being honest okay now I have a lot of
questions you guys will notice that
there's two songs playing at the same
time
why the [ __ ] this bothers me then nobody
points it out there's two songs at the
same time they're not even in harmony
there's like a soft piano riff and dude
strumming a guitar and they're different
[ __ ] songs
bro why what the [ __ ] okay breathe baby
like we've been practicing did you
notice your documents not facing her yet
idiot I've been your biggest fan
look how she's rubbing her belly to look
I've laughed at the same joke ten
thousand times I don't know which melody
to jam to what's worth it like when do
you call a bear with no teeth what do
you cuz I want a gummy bear bro
seriously move the [ __ ] on also our
issue is she deaf why is she not talking
he's you know I'm like why is no one
talking the music yeah how is nobody
pointing out that there's two songs
playing and conflict at the same time
that the just pulled away like that
anyway
I get the feeling he's blasting through
it too right like he's trying to time it
like yeah there's a time limitation on
Instagram or something breathe baby
young guys are telling me to breathe
only the nurse by the way you Britt you
breathe when you have a contraction like
only the nurse can tell you to breathe
in my opinion three Bush no don't push
it's like you're not doing anything so
you have to not say anything oh yeah
there's this moment she goes up wait
there's a great moment here when he goes
he basically is like oh yeah this is my
favorite luscious he goes people ask us
this is the best line ever did so
romantic he goes when people ask how we
made it this far what the [ __ ] you
talking about you look like you're 22 we
made it this far
I don't know then maybe there's like
known somewhere but I call them ok I
tell them a lot of Prayer a lot of
patience he's basically saying I cannot
stand you how do we make it this far a
lot of Prayer and a lot of patience for
your dumb [ __ ] gummy bear joke you
know what I'm saying like I'm not
flattering you're not you're not a
hundred years old you've been together
for like 80 years yeah a lot of Prayer
if how are you guys still together if
somebody asks you going to God right
that's not a compliment
somebody goes hell how did you guys you
guys are you know I think I've been
together so long a lot of Prayer and a
lot of patience that's something you
would hear from like your parents after
50 years of marriage yeah with like a
hint that they hate each other
yeah a lot of patience a rough a few
rough times already this is your first
pregnancy she gets me okay
breathe baby oh my god no patronizing
every time I see that breathe and wink
the night before our wedding day we were
sued some advice we'll never forget it
said don't forget to prayer we are going
to be tested but there is no test we
can't face together that's the advice
bro just like in the vows after two
years of being married that's it prayer
patience after two years dog did you
plenty of flats to you what's a test at
the Testaments like [ __ ] [ __ ] hit the
fan like they're having an awful like
what's an argument Oh a pregnancy lost
all no he finally got his good man you
look like idiots damn they've been
through plenty of prayer and plenty of
patience man he like yeah he gone and
did it to you man he had to do it to him
I got sucked into okay fine I'll give
you that but I still do not condone two
songs at once that [ __ ] is [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
don't tell me to breathe breathe it's
like yeah obviously I'm breathing I'm
not trying to die anyway yeah I'm over
this [ __ ] but like bro you're facing the
camera you're not facing her hello
right yeah so you and you read this so
you're not doing it right you got a
point in bit into the camera yeah so
it's like that can you read that
no I mean with that sighs not fired
probably meant but it's like this I'm
going okay breathe baby breathe
you're the most and it says like you're
the most breathtaking yeah I like some
more some of them were kind of long to
get the camera to by the way he's not
even looking at her he's facing the
camera so he's doing like this yeah
honestly I would be pissed because if
you were trying to make like a deal a
video out of it yeah
well she's in on it all right Ditka
Steve she's in there rubbing her belly
in whatever I just don't know why a be
Sue's ABC news got to get involved you
know what I mean there's two songs
playing out once what the [ __ ] just
being slightly thick in my mouth
I feel hate in my heart for this man if
my husband did this was in labor I would
have punched him in the face
exactly that's my feeling my feeling is
just like ready to punch I'm sure this
is an acceptable grounds for divorce and
I think that's when I knew the marriage
was over
he was definitely in on it guys set up
the camera and everything how the [ __ ] a
BC news gonna tweet that and then tweet
about Nancy Pelosi and Alan hearing like
come on you can't have it both ways dude
husband of the year all right so that's
cringe that's one aspect we're at a
break time let's take a break we got two
more crazy to breathe you ten breathe
the trend the cringe Trinity and then
we've got area 51 on the ground
reporting you guys this is uh this is a
big deal okay we'll be right back
hello fresh is America's number one meal
kit get easy seasonal recipes and pre
measured ingredients delivered right to
your door all you got to do is cook and
enjoy and if you guys go to hell of
fresh calm / h3 podcast 80 you're gonna
get eighty dollars off your first month
of hellofresh that's a freaking massive
discount now let me tell you about hello
fresh it's simple you get step-by-step
recipes with pre measured ingredients
all you have to do is follow the
instructions that they put on the sheet
and you're gonna have a WOW worthy
dinner on the table in just about 30
minutes and you get to say goodbye to
endless grocery store trips takeout food
forget about it you're gonna get a nice
home-cooked meal right freakin there
easy as pie you get all the joys of
cooking without all the schlep you know
what I'm saying
delicious break out of your dinner up
with hello freshest 20 plus seasonal
chef curated recipes each dang week you
got flexible you can add an extra meal
to your weekly orders as like some
bomb-ass garlic bread or cookie dough
you can change your delivery days food
preference skip a week whatever you want
look for example here look at this week
look at this [ __ ] crispy Parmesan
chicken Juicy Lucy burgers are you
freaking Kimmy pork carnitas tacos I
mean tell me when to stop
I'm not stopping so severe they add
geladas it's got five stars dude it's in
the Hall of Fame apparently truffle
umami blast burger come on and they're
gonna send you everything with
instructions pre packaged and you can
even my mom couldn't [ __ ] this up and my
mom's British she was some she burns
water literally I've cooked patella
fresh I think it's a lot of fun meaning
he'll love doing it you get all the food
it's exciting you see what's in the box
you cook it up yeah it's always good you
yeah that's it that's it the only thing
they're missing is like having a slave
come and clean your dishes then though
that would be a complete package but hey
there's probably something they're
working on for next quarter once again
guys $80 off your first month of
hellofresh go to hell affair
calm slashed a tree podcast ad and enter
the code a street podcast eighty
ridiculous ridiculous value hellofresh
calm slush h3 podcast 80 and enter h3
podcast 84 a doze off your first month
of hellofresh
got eesh
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer you already know about ring
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere you could
take it from me I've been on the
mountaintop shouting about ring they
help you stay connected to your home
anywhere in the world so if there's a
package delivered or a surprise visitor
you're gonna get an alert you're gonna
be able to see her see hear and speak to
them all from your phone you got HD
two-way audio features on the ring
device you got the spot lights you've
got the doorbell you've got so many
options let me tell you about my
spotlight not only do I get a motion
activate it's about these super bright
LED lights they'll blast the hell out of
anything coming down you get to see them
pop up you can talk to them even through
the spotlight and you can blast them
with an alarm be like hey dude I can see
your dumb ass I'm telling you this [ __ ]
is insane
they've got this and they've got this
neighbor app and all these people in
your neighborhood they're all connected
they're reporting incidents there
everyone's talking to each other I'm
this is weird this is ridiculous I love
the rink product if you are all
concerned about your safety in your
neighborhood or you just want to have
better tabs of what's going on around
your house the ring is is there's no
better product I mean like it's really
even even if you're not afraid you get
to see like raccoons and coyotes
wandering around the middle of the night
it's fantastic I saw a drunk guy a
stumble off my fence into my backyard
and walk all the way around my house at
like 3:00 a.m. I'm like dude that's uh
that's some wildlife right there you
know what I'm saying yeah I would have
never even knew that happen without ring
guys we got a special offer for our ring
starter kits available right now with a
video ring video doorbell motion
activated floodlight cam and the starter
kit has everything you need to build a
ring of security around your home here's
what you need to do go to ring.com slash
a tree that's ring.com slash HD I'm just
telling you start with the doorbell
you're gonna be addicted it's freaking
insane you can keep tags on all these
parks and friends and friends and family
but
nothing's gonna slip by
welcome back everybody I've got our on
the field reporter aka my brother Sean
who drove on though down to area 51 to
be on the field and get the get the
scoop as you guys know it's been in the
news lately area 51 they wanted to raid
area 51 someone made a Facebook group
that went viral everyone started
RSVP'ing yes for a meme there ended up
being like millions of people and on the
the lead-up to that this was a great
little scoop Dutch youtubers who were on
vacation were arrested and jailed when
they tried to get near area 51
leave it to youtubers who [ __ ]
everything up I mean really they are the
bottom tier they are the Dante's Inferno
lowest level though is being a youtuber
to Dutch friends said they wanted a good
look at the mysterious area 51 before
leaving the US they ended up in a Nevada
jail they were arrested about three
miles deep into the Nevada national
security site the site near area 51
which been focused on conspiratorial
theories for decades the two men say
they never planned to participate in the
raid they just wanted to do it the two
of them we didn't have any intention of
storm it because we leave on the day
before the actual storming date we just
wanted to go there good logic when
arrested on September 10th both men told
deputies they could read write and speak
English and had seen the no trespassing
signs at the entrance of the site but
they said they want to take a look at
the facility police said isn't there
science in area 51 that said like you
will be shot on sight if you enter like
they're very I don't [ __ ] around there
dude caution signs around area 51 you
know what I'm saying look at this [ __ ]
yeah hey you're not supposed to Beit
Shean what the hell Sean's on hold by
the way but we're getting that
restricted area no trespassing but on
this
point you will be ma isn't there one
that says that they'll murder people so
help me out here Dan six months
imprisonment
yeah that's pretty the murder part is
just implied something that was like
you'll be Shawn's right oh wow this was
outside area 51 this oh well that gives
it away warning area if you want the UFO
scooping up a guy yeah oh the funniest
part about this story that I'm leading
to is that so they pleaded guilty to
trespassing and illegal parking they
were sentenced to one year but it was
well it was suspended and the two will
spend a total of three days in County
each pay two thousand two hundred and
eighty dollars officials said they
wanted to make an example out of them
that area 51 is not a tourist attraction
they work this is my favorite part here
[Music]
when arrested he had they had on them
cameras phone laptop and a drone can you
imagine thinking you could just fly a
drone area over area 51 like these to
pose those youtubers God it doesn't get
any dumber than that I'm glad they
caught him what imagine if they said
though they're like they just flew a
drone over area 51 made a YouTube video
about it but they didn't well anyway
we've got my brother here like shunt the
great Sean Klein Sean welcome to the
show now Sean my brother of 34 years
Sean is two and a half years older than
me is that correct Sean two years nine
months older to be exact
Sean is a high school high school right
teacher yeah high school physics teacher
in Nevada he is beloved by the student
body he's a very good teacher
correct me at five I'm embellishing but
I don't think I am
I'll take credit for all that now a lot
of your students know you as my brother
right yeah I think is it is it the
likeness they think that the you that
you look like me and then they noticed
that you have the same last name as me
yeah I get this a lot we're like I'll
just like be teaching and like a student
cost me that I came mr. Klein do you
like do you know this like youtuber guys
came like h3h3 I'm like why you got like
the same last name now I'm just like um
you look kind of like him like yeah it's
my brother that or is it annoying it's
like whatever like it happens a lot kind
of that's kind of funny do you get it do
you find that you get extra respect from
the students when they find out you're
my brother yeah it like brothers like
yeah but then I'll get like this like yo
mr. Klein like I don't get it like your
brother seems like way different than
you I mean that's true we do a very
different plan I'm like yeah I'm a
teacher well well you understand we're
two different people
yes that's true yeah although we are
more we are very different more than
most siblings maybe but maybe not also
the same but people did always think we
were twins growing up so yeah well we
were pretty close in age and you were a
little bit taller for your age not a
little bit shorter a lot Detroiters
though not a lot don't be dramatic
don't be smarter than yourself I mean I
was pretty small well you've grown up
into a bright young man my brother's
jacked by the way I'm fat and he's very
jacked my brother
so you see him don't [ __ ] around you
know I'm saying that message to all his
students out there come across
have you ever has ABS ever been a fight
in one of your classes like a physical
fight um I've almost had a fight
what later last year I had this incident
where this girl went to the bathroom and
then another I let see we had like these
past these bathroom passes and so you
can let you out at the same time so I
let one girl out and she went to
bathroom and she was you know taking her
sweet time another girl goes into the
bathroom and she hears overhears her
talking about another girl in my class
and she's like talking [ __ ] about her
and so he comes back and tells the girl
yeah yeah and then they were like she
came back and they're like what you can
disrespected me and they start yeah yeah
sounds a little bit ratchet
you've been yes yes way sir would you
describe what you describe a
confrontation is ratchet someone told me
that term one of my duties that a little
ghetto I guess right gonna be the
definition lowest reality it was you
know it was it was it was unique I'm
gonna choose not to use any derogatory
absolutely smart keep stay professional
no they're they're great they're great
girl do you have any I mean the you know
you hear the trope about the hot female
teacher do you ever get any females
coming on to you as the as the handsome
you know single he's got muscles
I'm not saying does he [ __ ] his student
I mean of course he does I'm just
curious so what's the experience like as
a high school teachers I'm sure it's uh
there's a lot of ends and a lot of outs
Dan now Shawn answer the question
I think most most of the students are
pretty respectful
um I know like in my younger years as
I'm like 36 no one was 37 but when I was
a bit younger
a bit less gray hair I definitely like
had girls that like it was pretty clear
there was like a crush and I'd be like
hey yeah you are not staying after
school you know yeah yeah yeah that's
very smart very wise it will easier now
why cuz nobody there's less interest in
you because you're older yeah I'm older
now yeah and that way has there ever
been any sex scandals at your school
with like teachers and students um I
think they're so great that happens like
I I type I mean I've only I've owned
this is only my second year at this
school I think there was some case of
something like few years back but I I
can't I can't recall but I mean it's
like I know in in Vegas it's like it's
yeah this thing's definitely happened
but ya know I don't I don't know if any
of the cases I feel like all the
teachers when I was growing up were like
old and no one yeah no one would even
think to write yeah I reckon I was when
I was in school yeah like all they were
all like in their fifties and speakers
and it was like ah gross and then I went
back after right after I'd finished
college and I was doing substitute
teaching at my former school and like
all those old teachers had like retired
or died and they were all replaced by
like you know doing something fresh
blood yeah I can see yes I think in
Vegas I think those incidents happen
more than other districts because the
there's such high turnover of teachers
in in Clark County and so there's a very
large percentage of teachers that are in
twenties and thirties versus most
districts it's probably a smaller
percentage mm-hmm
imagine [ __ ] a high schooler as a
teacher ooh that sounds good no I'm
kidding that sounds awful Jesus Christ
well Shana that I'm glad that you have
yeah do you know come on that one so
this is my brother Sean a little
introduction to the man the myth the
legend himself now Sean I did an
incredible reporting he went out to area
51 on the day you did all the research
you did you got everything set up we've
got all a bunch of footage we're gonna
watch her shortly but I wanna can you
clarify for me Sean first of all there
was the original Facebook page but but
there was three different events that
happened there was the area 51 base camp
the alien stalk and then there was one
in Las Vegas that was hosted by the
original Facebook page owner can you
please explain what has going on with
those three events and how do they how
are they related so it's just like 21
year old college student guy and he just
thought it would be funny to post this
on this fake event on Facebook as like a
meme and it really started to take off I
heard that the there's that little not
video did you ever see that Oh what
about him that no they they took like
the where the old town Rose name yeah
mm-hmm yeah so there's that there's that
he he did like redid it it's like a
cartoon as like a mean I was like the
area 51 invasion after he saw this
Facebook event and then I could really
blew up Oh Madonna huh associated yeah
so yeah so anyway it became really
popular and it was like 2 million people
and like originally he thought you joke
but then he was like oh you know what
like maybe I can take advantages in mind
we can all like get the other and party
because he didn't want people to
actually storm at this one because he
was like that would be stupid
so he coordinated with the owner of the
low
alien hotel or in or Dever and in
Reichle and so they were in the process
of trying to organize something and he
said that he got kind of freaked out
because they didn't have a lot of permit
and he sought to be to my people and
there'd be all kinds of issues and then
he and my end up liable so he just like
cut ties with her and then he got
contacted by Budweiser they're like hey
we'll sponsor your event so he went and
sponsored an alien stock event in Las
Vegas but then the lady that owned the
end she was like well I got all this
free publicity so I'm gonna still host
it and so she's still hosted and called
the aliens clock would put like a hyphen
in it yeah so competing is correct and
then another company was like hey all
these would be coming up from Vegas but
let's make our own event
it'll be like more organized and stuff
and we'll have actual like speakers from
alien documentaries and books and try
and get some of that that crowd and
that's that's the one I was so you went
to so the one that you end up going to
was the area 51 base camp and this was
the one for the actual these are the
people that were ready to raid area 51 I
I don't I don't know about that but they
were they were the alien of whose words
I read it yet there was no definite like
I feel like if there were going to be an
alien furious they would be at this one
because this is where they had like do
an act first and it seems like yeah now
what I'm wondering is why on earth would
Budweiser think that a dude who only
qualification was making a Facebook page
could put on a festival yeah I don't
know but I on the local news they
covered it and it was like they were
like you know like 2030 people that's it
and it was a Thursday night like there
was only like 30 people at the Budweiser
sponsored [ __ ] I'm yeah I'm sure
loud the night there were more people
but yeah I wasn't very much
and what about alien stock they said
alien stock overall I think there were
like two to three hundred people that
showed up good and so ok so let's go to
area 51 base camp which is where you
were
now first let me ask you how many people
were at that one the total number of
people when I was there was probably
somewhere around a hundred hundred fifty
that's crazy there's nobody
yeah well and what makes it worse is the
vast majority of them were just that
page that oh yeah so Damon huh oh they
thought there'd be yeah they thought
there'd be thousands of people so the
owner the guy that organized it hired
all dis security they were like they're
like twenty thirty police officers that
he was paying to be there and he had
like additional security there were all
these like boo-boos and everything
they're like fifty porta-potties
oh yeah at one point I went use one
Queen of Sparta potty ever Wow Wow so
funny yeah those are the bankrolled uh
uh I don't think the guy is like I
thought I was there on someone from one
of the news channels was interviewing
him and he was really pissed yeah I know
I'd have to pay all these people
everyone was covering it like it's a
real thing you know the whole time the
Facebook group yeah in the noon news oh
you know absolutely like when I was
there there there were literally more
people from like the there were more
media people than there were idle event
that's awesome well it's a bit of a
schlep like if you don't live in Vegas I
mean even from Vegas it's like a
two-hour drive but if you're anywhere
else like [ __ ] driving there right yes
and you but you know what I thought it
wouldnt be like like this really
horrible like ugly does like I imagined
like like I thought of Independence Day
of Bruce Claus member like welcome her
you know
remember laughing oh yeah so that's what
I imagine and it's actually not like
that at all the area where it was it's
like really pretty there's like a river
I never liked trees and the lake and
stuff yeah I was like what hmm
that is surprising yeah the area 51 is a
little bit further east from there like
that like that this light is that like
the entrance but the total like area
that includes theirs if you wanted like
massive well let's let's I present to
you now Sean Klein presents an area 51
documentary stands aside Shane Dawson
we've got the area 51 documentary on
there and I'm very proud and excited to
present it to you guys here so let's
let's enjoy it together shall we here we
go a bunch of alien merch so hearty bro
there's like five how much money did
they spend on
yeah I don't have any Kevlar came off of
materials found on the Roswell crash my
Kevlar it's like not that crazy above
material
step the [ __ ] sidechain well we've
actually landed it's just a glare right
there the lighting in this shot is
insane yeah it's just a glare when you
heard memes are digital weapons you know
that that was a stand out line of the
evening and there's like there's
literally like 10 people in the shot
right now
yeah this is a crazy stage right I mean
this looks official
this is better than the one they had at
fire festival yeah this is actually
better put together than five yeah and
they had like 10,000 people
[Music]
[Music]
we only saw the one individual I was
there and she was ranting about some
environmental issues and she briefly
talked about Shawn was this the guy he
was talking about yeah yeah I went found
him I can't oh that's this guy's gone I
love hearing from this guy do you know
if this guy had an abduction experience
I should my guess is that he probably
does thank you cuz he says I can do
thing like most people get abducted I'm
assuming I don't wide enough that he
says because I noticed he says during
this interview that 5% of the population
has an abduction experience sounds like
you've got a dick sounds like an alien
put a probe up your ass with something
to do but anyway yeah I this is the real
deal so here we go this is that
the government's is sleeping in the debt
in in bed with the devil basically it's
a Faustian bargain that allowed us to
get this exotic technology so that was
basically in agreement between this
prevent technology German engineers were
then able to take that information and
eventually created prototype will be the
first working prototype in 1934 okay
they had a fully functional fleet of
your folks was it was it hard for you
not to uh was it hard for you to go with
the flow and not interrupt him with
facts a mug no I thought it would be but
like what he was saying was so out there
I was just like so fascinate I'm like
I'm gonna let this guy oh yeah that's
the right yeah I'm glad and you did a
great job of uh okay yeah we sir yeah we
starts talking about interdimensional
being oh my god I'm pretty sure Alex
Jones believes that and they're
connected to the Nazis yeah ever like
that's why I said directed by Steven
Spielberg because the villain who is not
seasoned is
what he's seek to overthrow they seek to
kill and steal and destroy human beings
by the way they really suck at killing
humans because like the population keeps
going up a lot from remove the stuff for
the better life but God bless that's
good yeah this guy's a legend man John
definitely did find out there sought to
kill it over it could be the know
they're fighting against and [ __ ]
they're telling you about [ __ ] chairs
that are [ __ ] this tall Shawn I
didn't follow the chair the chairs thing
yeah what is he talking about he goes on
he says that there's chairs that are
really small chairs is that there's
aliens could you supplement that with a
little yeah yeah so I guess he was
saying that he saw some evidence that
that they have like these these
narrative children 51 and they're very
small and so since they're small like
they're way too small for an adult human
so it must be for alien so they have
pictures of little chairs at area 51 do
they I nothing I'm gonna pair up I know
this guy didn't make a lot of sense well
I'm pretty sure he's on lots the drug
well there's one thing I do know for
sure that he did find the promise for a
better life in South different
happy firma absolutely that's just not
[ __ ] normal give a [ __ ] who you are
yes
describe to describe to me how a
[ __ ] chair this big is picking
anybody besides an alien and I'll
[ __ ] scream to the goddamn gods but I
think it's [ __ ] [ __ ] I think
guaranteed [ __ ] tell me I can't I
have to go to [ __ ] work in the
morning how much money do you think this
guy's in the paper No 500 bucks I don't
know he said this that yeah he's fine
think about but I can tell you only the
[ __ ] most brainwashed people who'd be
sitting around [ __ ] watching
theirselves dig [ __ ] I don't leave
another word
was it called when you [ __ ] sit and
deteriorate okay
where the [ __ ] else would they be I have
to say it looks like everyone there is
having fun looking legend what can I say
it's hard-hitting reporting yeah I would
have watched a full hour of this I would
have loved dude I would have totally
wash the floor now Shawn how did the cut
come out was there anything fantastic
that we neglected to include in the
final edit yeah I know I don't think so
I mean that kind of really captured the
the experience of a a lot of unique
characters well not really that many
characters but a handful unique
characters well did you get to see a UFO
well the big question you know I was
taught which someone the mum was saying
one of the guys I was talking to I think
after I stopped playing he was telling
me that like on the way here he saw you
up okay great fantastic yes I thought I
saw a drone okay that's what though if
they are forced actually like flew over
some crazy [ __ ] just to [ __ ] with
everyone there um well Shawn I would
like to congratulate you on a successful
mission out to there yeah base camp
you came back unharmed yeah you came
back with some golden footage you did a
great job and I look forward to sending
you on more journey of discovery would
you like to do more reports for us yeah
I think you're good at it I think you've
got a knack for this were you ever
were you ever in fear for your safety
out there
no because like I was telling people
that I was heading out there and
everyone's like because I post like an
Instagram photo like head in areas
and people are like oh my god be careful
you say let me know when you get back
I'm like why do people like so man let's
meet these utopian people they're like
they're like totally harmless yeah they
seem bald it's all go like it's crazy
the coverage of this story was just so
insane that everyone was thinking like
oh it was gonna be people ready to fight
and then the government is gonna fight
them yeah and it was gonna be like a
civil war going on and then it's the
media again like taking a story that
seems interesting and then completely
blowing ah yeah and this the government
or the Air Force was making statements
like don't yeah so it was all good but
everything we ended up with a fantastic
piece of journal I think that will go
down in the annals the anals of history
annals the anals of history so Sean we
wish you all the best thank you we wish
you well god bless god bless thank you
very much well there you have it
what was that talk to you later
talk to you later yes and there you have
it don't ever say that we hear the issue
podcasts do not hit hard okay we take
this job seriously one who says we don't
do our research were you at area 51
based a distance obviously and that's it
this is just the beginning of what did
our research was in area 51 we were
there boots on the ground mother-fricker
that's just the beginning of what we're
capable of we are not up and we're not
putting this show is only getting bigger
badder and crazier than ever now let's
talk about Justin Justin trade now we
shouldn't decide why you want to talk
about cuz overtime blast limited so
we'll talk about blackface okay Justin
Trudeau tree do Trudeau druid oh yeah
this story's just hilarious
I mean we're almost done but Justin
Trudeau can't stop wearing black
it's like the funniest [ __ ] ever now
look at that's like mega blackface
that's like no-holds blackface dude like
Oh what is a costume ma looks like just
some yeah it looks really dark in that
one I think ironically that's the brown
face photo though because it was too
black face picture can be deceiving
though a black and white picture right
exactly exactly well okay but regardless
I mean he had definitely a black face
long yes because everyone was like
calling for his resignation I was like
bro come on is the prime is he's not
gonna resign cuz he did blackface like
11 years ago it's part of a costume just
so stupid it's like you're telling me
that the person he is the person he's
become the Prime Minister of Canada all
he did Skull Minh aided in his life all
of his life's work and everything you
want him to resign
he's defined by this one moment 11 years
ago that you just found undo everything
he's worked so hard to becomes cuz he
wore black face 11 years ago listen to
yourself
[ __ ] you let me go through the anals of
your life and find something that's
embarrassing and try to get you fired
and yeah it's like it's like yeah you
really asked
and by the way Justin Trudeau's like
super liberal he's like a mega Lib
liberal like leader and they want him to
resign because he did blackface 11u you
know who's gonna replace him [ __ ] so
nice ultra-nationalist well so you're
gonna get yeah exactly you know who's
gonna who's gonna replace him he's gonna
run in blackface you know what I'm sayin
yeah that's what you're gonna get
[ __ ] idiots I'm so glad he didn't
like give in to that [ __ ] he was like
look I apologize
it was stupid thing to do I mean that's
some [ __ ] his hand is even dude
that's crazy dedication bro bro that's
crazy his hand is black
but what it's not like it's not like
he's doing this today exactly have you
seen my black face recently that's what
I'm saying
you wanna define him as a man everything
he's achieved in life because he did
like one thing he did 11 years ago bro
look how he's holding her neck though
too it's kind of wild huh mm-hmm damn he
apologize I should have known better
okay fair enough we could all look back
and say that thing you know I remember
when I was a kid how old am I now 34 it
was probably actually like 20 years ago
but there was trick-or-treaters who came
up in [ __ ] blackface what can you
know like where did yeah and nobody said
anything it was just like that kids
crazy but not like nobody thought that
kids a racist right he was just a
[ __ ] crazy to paint your face black
and go as a black person on Halloween
but no but like nobody cared nobody was
causing a fuss about it I'm just saying
not that big of a deal here I'm truly
shocked I don't know who this person is
Elizabeth May I'm truly shocked by the
racism showing the photograph of Justin
Trudeau you must apologize real harm
done and commit to learning and
appreciating the requirement to model
social justice leadership okay that's
fun he didn't she didn't call for his
resignation that's good hmm yeah okay
you can be shocked and he can make an
apology and we can and we can you know
use it as a learning experience that's
fine I
I support all that she's his website a
greatest thing though about this story
too is that he it it kept like coming
out is like a one after the other thing
like there was one story he was like I'm
sorry and then another one came out like
okay seriously I'm really sorry well
okay just made it seem a lot worse
because I'm getting dragged out like
that if he's doing blackface back then
he thought it was okay so and yeah he's
a serial blackface he's a serial
blackface costume like you is what any
defendant by the way this doesn't look
like blackface
it's a low quality black-and-white
picture here we got we've got the photos
here we got the receipts as the kids now
that's black me and Sam apparently
what's the context this one do you know
uh it was like uh it was like a camp or
something yeah he responds after the
second one came out the fact of the
matter is that I've always and you know
this been more enthusiastic about
costumes and it's sometimes appropriate
but these are the situation regret to
fight and you know this so I said I said
okay well let's see let's let's look
into the costume because I remember he
was getting kind of goofed on for this
whole thing where he would put on like
the Indian outfit
people were goofing on him so I do raise
this racist - I don't think so I think
he was just he was in India and he put
on the outfit yeah if that's racist then
what the [ __ ] is I don't understand
anything more I thought I thought that's
a nice gesture when you try - all right
I don't think anybody was calling this
okay they were just goofing on them I
don't okay and we just because he made
the defense about loving costume okay
like all these fish he's like he's like
- subtle shaves away from being yeah I
think that's a Canadian military uniform
oh yeah he's done at all I mean he's not
lying
dude he loves costumes goddamn Justin I
think that is I think that is legit
those are legit receipt okay now this
now this is troubling okay no this is
career-ending what is that a giant
pimple on his [ __ ] anyway yeah I'm on
your right the guy is a serial costume a
dresser they're all like high-quality
costumes and pigs and as the theater
geek and if I pull up this Aladdin
blackface you can tell like bro he got
the turb
he got yeah everything going on here I
mean this guy is all in he painted his
hand blocking [ __ ] sake when you paint
your hand black that goes beyond black
face I think that means he didn't
painted someone did for him there was
other people involved it's one of those
legit we need to find out who they are
and ruined their [ __ ] life too
what I did he said what I did hurt them
her people who shouldn't have to face
intolerance and discrimination because
of their identity this is something I
deeply deeply regret darkening your face
regardless of context of the
circumstances always unacceptable
because of the racist history of black
face I should have understood that then
and I should have never done it
god bless it's funny after it keep
caming out all these more black face
fuzz and he was like they're like have
you done this more than once and he's
like honestly I've probably done it
several times I can't really run that
room nice it seems harmless though yeah
anyone who wants a man to resign as
Prime Minister the prime of his life all
this man's life is culminated he's
achieved so much at such a young age to
resign and disgrace because he did black
faced 11 years ago give me a [ __ ]
break dude so was was he born like his
dad was a minister yes yeah now that's
it I mean I got a couple more things but
we can we come save them yeah it's my
dad's birthday and ah we gotta go get
grab some dinner with them so I'll put
up a I'll put a [ __ ] thing in it you
say that I'll put a pin in it what are
we talking about I'm gonna put a pin in
it put something in it I'm putting a pin
in it we can talk about it later okay
putting a pin in it you did you know how
I made it this far with you ela
a ton of right prayer bro and every day
I pray every day people ask that song so
sad
lots of prayer to God I've been asking
about every day please give me the
strength that's like you're one step
away from jumping out of the window lots
of Prayer patience good alright so
that's it that are we looking how long
we looking good we looking gold we're
looking Goldie so on Friday we've got
Casey nice tat the OM that I'm using the
Casey nice that phone he's gonna like
that he is gonna love that so so you
know catch us on Friday and then the
next week after that we got Bobby Lee
and kalila coming in the grades that
we've got don't we have more guests
lined up when is the bachelor gonna
bachelor finale we got it and we there's
we got a lot three that's right
oh [ __ ] Oh next week I think we're
talking about next Friday
yeah next Friday but we got we got some
planning to do because we're already
getting inquiries for the next Bachelor
I think we have a I think we have a a
bachelor for the next season
mm-hmm we got I know why we gave it away
yet but we will announce it on the last
I was a very eligible he's very
accomplished
he's gainfully get very gainfully
employed yeah and I'll say that dare I
say that he's got a touch of magic and
divinity in him as well right yeah in AD
Wow is that a hint yeah yes it is Dan
but until then I wish you a chase
Tuesday so have a great week I'm gonna
see on fry or not well tomorrow you know
you see it on Wednesday not to z' day
because it's a late we had to start
later because it was a ceremony but I do
want to say and as I close out this
podcast how meaningful it is that you've
come here
and become a citizen of the under the
you've stood on the shoulders of the
Great's like Thomas Jefferson George
Washington Alexander Hamilton and window
and when the you know when the English
camp doors when they rolled into New
York Harbor with 32,000 troops and the
world looked upon America like ants
fools these ideals of freedoms idealists
naive they would this they said that
those ideals of freedom stand now over
two hundred years later as a testament
people often say what would the founding
fathers think of America today you know
what they would say and they would say
they would probably cry tears of joy
that their that the country they oh come
on you can't move America was that a
boot yeah what are you buying
no America is beautiful one day I would
say the it worked the Constitution that
we wrote the Bill of Rights will
everything we dreamed up birthday for
200 years ago can you imagine that they
dreamed it will become the imminent
superpower of the world coast-to-coast
specific to Atlantic sea the sea to
shining sea Dan
we got a mobility scooter you imagine
the tram read on what is friction a blue
Dan I mean seriously you can go on
Google and buy a mobility scooter and
it's delivered to you the next week sea
to shining a merry intersteno regional
states 250 I run out of song I mean come
on we'll give me the American music Dan
for track I've been waiting for for this
whole time you know I mean it's fine it
doesn't matter that we can get genocided
millions of Indians her about her heyday
we had a manifest destiny God told us we
must we must
oh the land from sea to shining sea
those manifest destiny it was a national
policy there no other thing on the
western frontier basically they had this
Christian funded a policy called
manifest destiny said that God destined
us to have from coast to coast and that
and it didn't matter what we had to do
because it was God's plan for America
didn't matter if we had to kill Indians
didn't matter if we had to kill Mexicans
of which we killed many we it was the
American promise sea to shining sea that
of course came much later than the
founding fathers they had nothing to do
with that so don't bring them into it
well manifesto you got a well a manifest
destiny came late after all the founding
fathers and already set the groundwork
for the great country we live in today
dan what are you a historian what are
you [ __ ] give me a break here okay
it didn't know well the constitutional
questions yeah yeah I will Dan dude me
when I said I started now I do think
that we need to add an amendment to the
Constitution about mobility scooters
what would it say that every every
person can buy one mm-hmm
I think that Lord he is the case but
good I gotta think about it but I think
it's gotta be there that would be the
38th amendment right 28th 28th amendment
all right so what we got to read our
congressman you gotta write the Brad
chairman chairman that would be the
weirdest [ __ ] note he ever got baby
no that's beautiful that's three of our
great Republic a Republic for which it
stands indivisible I do need I I think
mobility scooters should be a little
cheaper it was a little peasant man it
needs to be substituted by the
government some sort of subsidy yeah
sort of so it's a it's not a it's not a
privilege it's alright yeah it is
alright okay all right well you let's
get you okay slow down you just been
American for one day okay could you slow
down it's always the commitment to own
one all right let's say that it's
alright
slow it down there's it's almost our
responsibility is
American citizen I'm throwing him
abilities good all right I got one plane
right now
hey pace yourself okay got a whole life
I had to get being an American okay from
sea to shining sea huh
well guys it's been a fun packed field
we're gonna go at some barbecue do them
so what the [ __ ] up now baby yes mac
and cheese mac uh maybe have some
broccoli if it's sauteed in butter
otherwise it's all spitless oh well
[ __ ] [ __ ] on the table I will
literally show you why don't you eat the
spinach that's cooked in butter and
create that [ __ ] tastes like garbage why
would you even I don't get that like I
hate cream of spinach it's awful who is
a dream it's just a heap of nasty soggy
spin it's not cream and it's not spam
and you eating it like oh well you want
to eat spinach because it's healthy but
you know it's just coated in butter it
doesn't even taste good I mean who would
eat that I don't know correct me if I'm
wrong tanner Ian do you like that [ __ ]
and when Zach WA yeah yes you know I am
why don't I want you to tell me the
truth the cream of spinach [ __ ] yeah I'm
sorry what in the show you know you're
not listening I'm just watching your
mouth you don't listen
yeah we just keep it on mute back here
to be honest mmm true okay so so which
so do you enjoy it yes or not first of
all we're almost in the same room do you
not hear us anyway like but and also the
door got busted oh but I'm not gonna
tell you in I'm not gonna tell you what
we were talking about we've been ranting
about it for like five minutes
well you gotta take a gamble do you like
it or not the thing that you don't know
yeah well you did say I would like yeah
I heard that part and there you go I'll
take your I trust you
say yes you [ __ ] up don't ask your
disgusts me
rap you disgust me I can't believe that
you would heat back that came on you
let's send it out thank you it was cream
of Spanish
[Music]